hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play black
snow we are just about to get into the
darkness which I have a bad feeling
about like I do with most of these games
it is exceptionally dark down here
let me save oh hello hi light nice tan
you Wow
what is that what is that I heard a
thump e thump I hear something
skittering around in the darkness
keycard what the hell was that good god
man
it was just a black moving shadow and
wasn't even anything I have no idea what
that was I have no idea what the hell
was that
oh man okay I'm just gonna stand here
until I heal up with I don't know what
the hell I'm gonna do in there I've got
no it's just blackness who's just
blackness I've got no flashlight I've
got no protection with this little safe
hail me oh no it doesn't seem to work
I've ran of healed heal heating juice
how have I sucked all of the heat out of
that oh I opened it I can only open the
black ones I need
open up the door leave that door open
please thank you
Oh what oh it's an owl I was weird
okay that dark that's gonna come back or
what like seriously for seriousness I
hear something I'm gonna go back out
there I didn't like that the first time
I think I'll like it a lot less the
second time Wow Wow it's like a stinky
black shadow I see you I do you I see
you looking at me what are we gonna do
I'm trapped I'm trapped I'm trapped I am
trapped I am I am I am everything except
safe right now I do not know what to do
about that sorry I Spit I don't know I
don't know okay I'm just gonna make a
run for it okay okay here we go you
can't sprint no sprint juice oh god it's
dark we're about yarn I totally lost
I totally lost I'm gonna go towards I
like woohoo let me let me let me you
can't come in here
you can't come in here really nice
portal particle effects by the way oh
shut up
Oh God what the hell is that huh stop
opening that freaking door you bull
honkey what I see oh that's a magic
heater healer heal me heal me huh save
here I think I do not like this Sam I am
I do not like green eggs and ham this is
oh man that's terrifying I can't go out
there I don't have a do I have a
flashlight maybe I just got the controls
wrong and I technically do aah aah
autofocus please focus it on me thank
you I don't do dogs taking my soul for a
second there okay so let me check in
here can I open these can I open this is
there any reason for me to be in here
probably not okay
saving not gonna suck up any more of the
healing juice and okay maybe maybe there
is I'm not looking at controls maybe
there is a primary attack I do not have
okay so these are just standard
half-life controls okay
sounded like the ATV suit whenever I got
hurt what are we gonna do haha what am I
gonna do you're right there
Oh GUI I don't want any GUI GUI please
like I would like to be alone
I can't leave and open the door again
that's right there in the doorways it's
left last time it left oh go away
whatever you are can you go away please
you leave I hear something skipper
scampering okay I'm just gonna make a
run for it again hey ha Oh perfect
darkness go go go go go go go Hey look
energy drinks completely not copyrighted
a generic brand vanilla drink hmm my
favor Javel hi I do not like this Cape I
do not like this game but I'm cool I'm
brave I'm tough gonna I see another area
over there I don't like this game I
don't like this game
I don't like this game I like this game
but I don't like this game I don't like
this game
it would be nice if I knew what I was
fighting here instead of just inky
blackness
okay I've ran out of heating juice right
does not seem to work that is equally as
dark that is also equally as dark I do
not have a flashlight
oh hello oh go in the mailroom thank you
it's too dark to read you're kind of all
up in the doorway please go away
please go away hi hey buddy stop that
there like a light switch in here what's
over here what's over here
I see something under water go where am
I where am I okay hello baby
just good drink my coffee act like
nothing weirds happening why didn't I
come in here with a gun that would have
been nice that would have been real nice
yeah I know you're in the doorway no no
onion oh no no you can't give me in here
I mean the light I'm in the lightness
okay what do I need to do do I need to
do you're over there I see something
over there save maybe if I push that box
out of the way I'll be okay you'll be
okay you'll be okay push it put that
buzzer what punch punch punch
[ __ ] it no okay
no don't come over there come over here
okay okay hi yeah hi hi hi oh there's
two of you you both come over here okay
good ah holy balls you can reach far
into this room okay I'm gonna push it
I'm gonna push I've almost pushed it I
vow
light light light light light give me on
Oh Oh God
god damn oh man this game this goes dark
in here it's dark in here it's dark in
here it's dark in here how can I make it
light I want to make it light I want the
light I want the light please I am in
the main building right at the entrance
here's aa light huh
that's there thank you thank you thank
you
can you daddy do you call an ambulance
or daddy it's dark and cold out here I
got to move wherever I'm moving next
really quickly which is I don't know
where I might I might actually freeze to
death out here I don't know where I'm
going haha I should have looked at the
map better because I know that there
were other places around ha ha
yes yeah yeah yeah and the kennels Oh
balls kennels are balls balls are balls
wow wow wow oh god I'm on time a diamond
diamond diamond I I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die oh thank you
oh then baby maybe I'll let me in let me
in let me in I mean let me in somewhere
I mean somewhere all got him on a
diamond a diamond a diamond a diameter
diameter diameter die I'm gonna die I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dad I'm dad I'm dad I'm
better than dead I'm dead I'm the frozen
corpse I'm quite literally frozen and
dead I can't
[Music]
- cold can't feel penis and balls cannot
feel anything okay
so that was stupid of me let's try it
again
with a little less failure okay so if
I'm here I went down to the kennels
there's a toolshed ah so that's
economists if I keep going straight and
turn to the left or if I go right I can
go the hanger let's try the hanger
ah the toolshed sound like it's
important there's probably some
flashlights in there maybe okay if I go
straight here
I can't sprint I don't know why I wish I
could sprint I would be nice well a lot
of things would be nice in this game
like light and warmth and happiness and
maybe like you know it's not too much to
ask maybe like going home that'd be nice
okay there is a toolshed out here
correct correct oh my god the toolshed
has exploded
what are you something is engraved on
the plate I can't read it because I'm
about to freeze to death is that burning
is that fire it's not helping me okay
the toolshed has exploded I can't read
what it says what does it say a forlorn
night comes they reside behind the
knowledge lies the truth
okay I'm gonna freeze again but at least
I read that good good
I don't know good bad did something for
me maybe I don't know I don't know while
I'm dying let me just cuz I'm not gonna
make it back anyway whoa there's a dead
dog seem to have frozen to death that
sounds familiar we just go around see if
there's another entrance my last five
seconds of life I do commit these last
three seconds to no one cuz I hate you
all I hope you die with me
okay no I just I'm just kidding I love
you all I love you okay I'm gonna make a
right this time and right out to the
right here
I do have to say though that this game
is an exceptional game I mean I really
like it I mean I really like it it is
well done to the max what's going on
here hanger I can't get in Oh can't get
in that door either and sounds familiar
I'm just gonna make a loop around the
building here see if I can't find
something before I freeze to death this
hanger sure is big is there a plane in
here then I can escape in or on I'll
take either one nope it's just a big big
big plane of nothingness
just like my soul empty and black bleak
as my future bleak as the water I walk
on love existentialism I don't know okay
there was nothing that was quite
literally nothing and I'm going to
freeze to death again three times in a
row new record personal past I am what
is this what is this wait what is this
what is this what is this what is this
what are you are you the hanger again no
cuz you're something new
are you alright like just an idiot I'm
just an idiot on it you're still the
hanger aren't you I must run all right
so I'm not exactly sure where I'm
supposed to go from here
let me take another look at the map I
might have to go back in that might be
something that I need to do the
generators over there at research
there's two research labs I don't think
I went in one I might have to go back in
I don't want to do that though I do not
want to so um if you guys know which way
or where I'm supposed to go at the
moment please let me know in the
description below um I'm really I really
like this game it's very creative it's
very well made
I don't know it's just good altogether
and those things those black things are
terrifying in the darkness inside there
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]